and then I feel like another part of it
is that it's this whole toxic
masculinity narrative these days because
I feel like women used to know that men
needed their spaces like even when I
speak to my mum about it she's a bit
older Italian a bit more sort of a bit
more based and she'll say she'll kick
her partner out of the door and say go
hang out with the guys because they kind
of knew that men need that space they
need to chop it up a little bit but now
anytime men want to hang out together
and have men's spaces and have a bit of
locker room talking a bit of banter all
of a sudden it's toxic masculinity and
there's these adverts where guys are
saying hey mates stop doing like
off like just let us have our spaces I
get sometimes and I'm pretty PG with
this stuff but sometimes I get women who
will message me on Instagram or email
these really sort of upset messages
saying I can't believe that you said
this this and this and I'm like
okay it's not meant for you I was
speaking to guys like I wouldn't come
and tell you I can't believe you watched
Oprah because you know I wouldn't do
that I just let you have your girl space
let you listen to your WAP and your
cardi B and you let me do my thing so I
don't know do you reckon that it's a
little bit of the fact that women don't
really get men as much these days and
what we actually need
very few women understand males and what
see there's a big difference between
males and Men right like there's a lot
of males out there there's not a lot of
men out there right and again that's
that's because men are letting women
invade their spaces that's because we're
listening to females that are in
positions of power now
um seeing some of the dumbest I've
ever heard in my entire life like you
know the phrase toxic masculinity
there's no such thing as toxic
masculinity there's just masculinity
it's only called toxic when it doesn't
serve you or if it's not doing something
that you want it to do when there's a
war when there's a flood when there's a
hurricane that flattens an
entire State and you know men are needed
to go in and rescue with helicopters and
fire trucks and boats and there's women
and children that are dying or getting
hurt
um that's that's when masculinity is
appreciated right but they don't call it
toxic masculinity then that's still
conventionally masculine it's it's only
called
toxic masculinity when they can't
control you right you know if you see a
guy out on the street and he's wearing a
Maga hat or something to that effect oh
he's toxically masculine
dizzy though or does he just have an
opinion that's different from yours you
know the funny thing about people and
their opinions is they don't really want
to hear your opinion they seem to want
to hear their opinion coming out of your
mouth and that's what this crowd of of
uh folks are I believe anyway that
generally point and sputter at
conventionally masculine men calling
them toxically masculine that's all they
are
um they're just envious and essentially
they want to be with a guy like that but
they probably can't uh you know just
just because the nature of their lives
and they're not being chosen right you
know you see a lot of these women on
apps like Tick Tock and they're like I'm
a conventionally liberal woman and all I
keep finding with guys that I like is
that they're all conservative or they're
Republican why why can't I find a good
liberal guy that is also good looking
what do you want sweetheart right I mean
do you want a Ferrari that also gets 100
miles to the gallon because they don't
exist like like pick you know like
choose what you want I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out